are you doing good good last year you
said this was like being parachuted on a
runaway train has it gotten better yeah
now you'll feel that way I feel like I
didn't fall off the train fair enough
who knows I'm still on the train yeah so
that's that's how it feels like it feels
like now I'm moving closer and closer to
the front cart you were part of the cast
day one when did you feel like you were
part of the family
day one did you really yeah they won you
know you know I think a lot of it has to
do with with my experience and and it
know being stranger to to long-running
shows you know I think understanding
what it takes
appreciating cool you know more than
anything I think that the secret sauce
for for having fun on set is to you know
to really reach out and get to know your
crew sure you know the the crew is it's
not the location it's not the sound
stages it's not where your shoe it
really is the crew is the home yeah
that's where you feel oh I'm at home you
know you see the same faces that becomes
your environment and becomes your
atmosphere so I think that is what makes
it feel home so if you're an actor that
you know any actor you know watching
this and you go to a movie and you go
movie set or more a TV show setting and
you don't feel 100% comfortable you've
not done your job by reaching out to
your crew and and and and making sure
that you feel like you know they feel
and you feel like you guys are in it
together right and that's where home is
okay when it comes to the fans jumping
on a show like this now you got one
season behind you going into another one
here the responsibility that you must
feel for sure there's been on the air 15
years with the fans that they love this
show so talk about the responsibility of
not letting those fans down who have
been with this thing since the beginning
I mean I'm pretty sure that a lot of
people put that pressure on themselves
you do not I know my lines I swing as
hard as everybody else my only hope is
that they
you know the hours that were putting in
on screen yeah but but I I will tell you
you know and it's a gift you know it's a
blessing to be on a show that notes
itself so well that that is beloved by
the audiences on a global scale the way
it is so it's more it's more just
refreshing to be able to be at a show
that that that continuous
continuously you know delivers something
so loved by people you know and so I I
just think for me was more about can I
contribute yeah to what's already
happening you know what I mean I think
that was that was mostly my my
commitment to myself was okay you know I
gotta create something the show has
never seen I gotta I gotta do a
character that feels like it's been
there before yeah that's the homework I
had to put in you know the pressured man
you you start thinking about the
pressure stuff you know you you won't
sleep you know and then you start
messing up at work you know but I think
it's more about you know just wanting to
really do a good job for your crew and
for mark and in the cast Canada loves
them some more Carmen yeah what is now
that you're with them on as regularly as
you as you are have you figured out what
yeah Mark Harmon thing is what is it I
have I have and I I fell into the trap
yes I fell in the trap the moment I
stared into this ocean blue eyes and I
lost myself in a draft into his you know
voice I just knew there was no way I
could return all been there he's voice
his poetry and he's you know aura is the
Sun you know my Carmen is all that in a
bag of salt sea salt and vinegar chips
but no I'm telling you I get it you know
I get it he's you know what he does for
his character is one thing right what he
does to people when you meet them you
walk away with with a piece of him you
know he gives so much and gives himself
so much into his heart he loves his fans
and loves the show and loves his
co-workers and and really when you're
unsaid you know he makes you feel like
we're on the same floor
there's no ham being the number one TV
actor in the history of our generation
true you know because he is the biggest
TV star in the planet yeah okay but but
he doesn't make you feel that way you
know you go to set and he's so humble
and so sweet and so giving is so
empowering and every time I work with
him we laugh we laugh our butts off all
day long and we've become pretty close
friends Pauly's last season have there
been talks at all of how that's gonna be
treated this is a tough gabbai on a show
well you know you know know what this
there hasn't really been any real
conversations about it I think that
right now we're focused and we still
have so much shell to shoot yeah you
know we're an episode
I don't like 10 or 11 out of 24 right
you know we still have a long season to
go so I think it's really the focus is
on continuing to give amazing episodes
and and to use every character in the
most efficient way possible you know and
and you know it's the evolution of the
show you know I think you a 15 years you
know someone's allowed to you know to
hang them up
you know what I mean I think it's it's
important that people do it as long as
they love it you know I'm sure you've
heard this from the fans I'm sure you
have people in your family but is there
a going to be an NCIS Los Angeles and
New Orleans sort of thing I've always
this is where I've been pitching man and
I'm having some major conversations
about this there is members in each one
of those shows that I love so much that
if put together somehow it'd be the
Avengers of NCI
okay so so I definitely I definitely in
pitch in a world where all three shows
have to come in for some monster you
know national you know threat so I think
it could happen I don't I'm not saying
there's any conversation sure but if if
Wilmer was running the network of the
studio
I'd be like hmm how do we connect the
ironmans and the Thor's and the Captain
America's of all this shows and and do
something and television television has
never done before perfect brilliant